welcome back in the last video we were
just figuring out the volume under the
surface and we had set up these integral
bounds so let's see how to evaluate it
now and look at this I actually realize
that I can scroll things which is quite
useful because now I have a lot more
board space so how do we I evaluate this
integral well the first integral I'm
integrating with respect to X right I'm
adding up the little X sums so I'm
forming this rectangle right here right
or you can kind of view it I'm holding Y
constant and integrating along the
x-axis I should switch colors so what's
the antiderivative of XY squared with
respect to X well it's just x squared
over two and then they'll have the Y
squared that's just a constant all over
two and I'm going to evaluate that from
X is equal to 1 to X is equal to the
square root of Y which you might be
daunted by but you'll see that it's
actually not that bad once you evaluate
them and then let me draw the outside of
the integral this is y is equal to 0 to
Y is equal to 1 dy now if X is equal to
1 this expression becomes y squared over
2 right y squared over 2 minus now if X
is equal to square root of Y what is
this expression become if X is equal to
the square root of Y then x squared is
just Y and then Y times y squared is y
to the third right so it's Y to the
third over 3 fair enough and now I take
the integral with respect to Y so now I
sum up all of these rectangles in the Y
Direction 0 1 this is with respect to Y
and that's cool right because when you
take the first integral with respect to
X your hold you end up with a function
of Y anyway so you might as well have
your bounds as functions of Y's it
really doesn't make it any more
difficult but anyway back to the problem
what is the anti derivative of the Y
squared over 2 minus y to the 3rd Y to
the third over 3 well the antiderivative
cubed you have 2/3 so it's y cubed over
6 minus y to the fourth you have 2
divided by 4 minus y to the fourth over
did I mess up someplace no I think this
is correct y to the fourth over twelve
right Y to the fourth 408 how did I get
a three here that's where I messed up
this is a 2 right I this is a what let's
see X is square root of Y yeah this is a
2 I don't know how I ended up right
square root of Y squared is y times y
squared Y to the third over to right and
then when I take the integral of this
it's four times two eight got to make
sure I don't make those careless
mistakes that's that's the tough part I
just want to make sure that you got that
too I hate it when I do that but I don't
want to re-record the whole video so
when I evaluated this right this is
right and then I take the antiderivative
of Y to the third over two I get Y to
the fourth over eight and now I evaluate
this at 1 and 0 and that gives us what
1/6 minus 1/8 minus well both of these
when you validate Mizzy are going to be
0 so it's going to be you know 0 minus 0
so you don't have to worry about that so
what's 1/6 minus 1/8 see 24 that's 4
minus 3 over 24 which is equal to one
twenty-fourth is the volume of our
figure is the volume of this figure so
this time we the way we just did it we
we took we we took the integral with
respect to X first and then we did with
respect to Y let's do it the other way
around so let me erase some things and
hopefully I won't make these careless
mistakes again
I'll keep this figure but I'll even
erase this one just because
let me erase all of this stuff if room
to work with so kept that figure but let
me redraw just the just the XY plane
just so we get the visualization right
it's more important to visualize the XY
plane in these problems than it is to
visualize the whole thing in 3d that's
the y-axis that's the x-axis y X okay
our upper bound you can say is the graph
y is equal to x squared y is equal to x
squared or you could view this the bound
x is equal to square root of Y that is X
is equal to 1 that's Y is equal to 1 and
we care about the volume above the
shaded region right that shaded region
is this yellow region right here now
let's draw our da our so our da I'll do
a little square actually and I'll do it
in magenta so that's our little da and
the height is dy that's a y dy and its
width is DX right so the volume above
this little square that's the same thing
as this little square just like we said
before the volume above it is equal to
the value of the function right the
height is the value of the function
which is X Y squared and then we
multiply it times the area of the base
well the area of the base you could say
it's da but we know it's really you know
dy times DX dy times DX I don't have to
write that times there you can ignore it
and I wrote the Y first just because
we're going to integrate with respect to
Y first we're going to sum in the Y
direction so what is something in the Y
Direction mean I mean we're going to add
that Square to that square to that
squares excuse me so we're summing in
that we're adding all the D Y's together
right so my question to you is what is
the upper bound on the Y well once again
we bump into the curve right so the
curve is the upper bound when we go
upwards
and what is the upper bound on the curve
well we're holding X fixed
so at any for any given X what is this
point well that's going to be x squared
right because this is the graph of y
equals x squared so our upper bound is y
is equal to x squared and what's our
lower bound we can take keep adding
these squares down here where we're
adding all the little changes in Y so
what's our lower bound
well our lower bound is just zero that's
pretty straightforward and then so once
we so this expression as it is written
right now
is d is the volume above this rectangle
right it's the volume above let me draw
it is the volume above this rectangle
these are the same rectangles the volume
above that rectangle now what we want to
do is add up all the D X's together and
we'll get the volume above the entire
surface so that rectangle now we'll add
it to another DX 1 and DX 1 like that so
what's the upper and lower bounds on the
X's we're going from X is equal to 0
right we don't bump into the graph when
we go all the way down so we go for X is
equal to 0 and then our upper bound is X
is equal to 1 X is equal to 0 x is equal
to 1 and in general a one way to think
about it is when you're doing this outer
the kind of the last sum or the last
integral you really shouldn't have
variable boundaries at this point right
because our final answer has to be a
number assuming that you know that we're
not dealing with something very very
abstract but our final answer is going
to have a number so if you had some
variables here you probably did
something wrong
it's always useful I think to draw that
little da and then figure out ok I'm
summing to dy first when I go upwards I
bump into the curve what is that upward
bound affects this constant oh it's x
squared y is equal to x squared if I go
down I bump into the x-axis or Y is
equal to zero and so forth and so on so
now let's just evaluate this and confirm
that we get the same answer so we're
integrating with respect to Y first so
that's X Y to the third over 3 at x
squared and 0 and then we have our outer
integral X goes from
1dx if we substitute x squared in for y
x squared to the third power is X to the
sixth X to the sixth times X let me
write that so we have x times x squared
to the third power over three that
equals x to the seventh X to the seventh
right X to the squared the third you
multiply the exponents and then you add
these X to the seventh over three minus
this evaluated with y is zero but that's
just going to be zero right
and then we evaluate that from 0 to 1 DX
we're almost there
increment the exponent you get X to the
8th over 8 and we already have a 3 down
there so it's over 24 and you evaluate
that from 0 to 1 and I think we get the
same answer when you evaluated 1 you get
1 24 minus 0 so once again when we
integrate in the other order you still
get the volume of the figure being 128
forth whatever cubic units anyway see
you in the next video